[Musique]
le 17 octobre à la massacres coloniaux
tente le préfet a fait le tour des
postes de police en disant pour un coup
reçu vous en donnerai 10 pour les
policiers qui entendent ça si vous
voulez et bien c'est un permis de tuer m
[Musique]
le 17 octobre 1961 quelques dizaines de
milliers d'algériens sorte pour répondre
à un appel de la fédération de france du
fln a
bravé à boycotter un couvre-feu qui leur
a été imposée à eux et à eux seuls ceux
qu'on appelle les français musulmans
d'algérie à ce moment là par le
gouvernement de michel debré et le
préfet de police maurice papon
c'était bien
expliqué qu on le devait porter rien sur
nous pas même une épingle à nourrice
parce qu'on avait bien précisé que cette
marcherait pacifique le préfet de police
maurice papon est prévenu assez tard de
l'initiative et ils disposent dès le
matin des forces de police considérables
qui sont armés
façon très très très importante
le premier événement du 17 octobre c'est
d'abord une des plus grandes rave de
l'histoire de france puisque selon la
préfecture de police en quelques heures
ce sont onze mille cinq cents
manifestants qui sont embarqués c'est
considérable et au début les camions de
police suffisent puis on doit
réquisitionner pour ça les bus de la
ratp
la dernière fois que les bus de la ratp
en service était en juillet 1942 lors de
la rafle du vel d'hiv
imaginez vous dans la rue et vous voyez
des corps par terre avec du sang avec
des menottes si c'est le cas il n'y a
pas de mots placés dans les futures ont
été jetés dans la seine et j'en ai vu
qui ai essayé de s'accrocher
des buissons qui était le hauban de la
scène pour essayer de se former
dans la nuit même du 17 au 18 octobre
sans attente du tout la fin des
événements maurice papon sera comme
unité de presse qui dit qu il y a eu
trois morts alors c'est évidemment une
version outrageusement mons mensongères
par exemple les archives de la brigade
fluviale qui repêchaient les cadavres
dans l'est dans les cours d'eau ont
disparu alors qu'ils étaient sous la
responsabilité du préfet maurice papon
qui restait préfet jusqu'en 1967 donc dû
le temps de faire un certain ménages eh
bien on comprend que le bilan exact on
ne le connaîtra jamais
[Musique]
l'explication
elle vient en grande partie du fait que
le pouvoir gaulliste à ce moment là est
divisé en réalité parce que de gaulle
négocier avec le fln mais à matignon il
ya michel debré qui lui est un partisan
farouche de l'algérie française
et lui fait tout ce qui est tout ce qu
il peut que gêner ces négociations et il
a écarté par exemple un ministre de la
justice qui était extrêmement
favorables à la négociation qui
s'appelait dont michelin il a écarté un
ministre de l'intérieur et il les a
remplacés par des gens qui sont des durs
alors notamment roger frey au ministère
de l'intérieur et puis il ya maurice
papon qui fait partie du même groupe
c'est un pacificateur coloniale qui est
là parce qu'il a appris
d'abord au maroc puis en algérie à
réprimer férocement le nationalisme nord
africain et ses voilà que la chaîne de
commandement qui explique un petit peu
l'étrangeté politique apparente de cet
événement c'est c'est ça
[Musique]
il faut quand même imaginer un peu entre
58 et novembre 1961 jaya 47 policiers de
la préfecture de police qui sont tués 47
tués et 137 qui sont blessés et beaucoup
très gravement ils sont tétraplégique
qui son fauteuil roulant ce sont des
gens qui rêvent de vengeance un bien sûr
qu'ils se sentent ciblé le injustement
quelque part
[Musique]
et papon quelques jours avant a fait une
tournée des postes de polices et c'est
là qu'il tient sa fameuse phrase un pour
un coup reçu vous en donnerai 10 et
cetera pour les policiers qui entendent
ça si vous voulez et bien c'est un
permis de tuer en tout cas vous n'aurez
pas il n'y aura pas de conséquence quel
que soit votre attitude
[Musique]
la presse pose des questions et met en
doute la version officielle de papon
mais le gouvernement va tenir bon il va
obtenir le silence en empêchant une
commission denquête ont saisi 100 en
censurant des journaux et puis surtout
quelques mois après il ya les accords
d'evian la fin de la guerre et et une
page que les français eux sont pressés
de tourner le plus vite possible
et l'événement va finir par tomber dans
l'oubli
[Musique]
il se lance dans la collecte de
témoignages très nombreux ils utilisent
les archives qu'on a bien voulu le
laisser à utiliser et il construit un
récit un contexte contextualise
l'événement et lui rend sa rationalité
politique et donc c'est le premier acte
de jean luc einaudi mais ça va pas
s'arrêter là puisque il va le fait
d'avoir écrit ce livre va l'amener à
être confrontés directement à maurice
papon lors de procès
[Musique]
la république reconnaît avec lucidité
c'est fait cinquante et un ans après
cette tragédie je rends hommage à la
mémoire des victimes
[Musique]
pour la revendication aujourd'hui comme
à l'époque c'est que il ya une parole
qui reconnaissent nettement donc cette
affaire comme un crime d'état c'est à
dire un crime qui a été fabriqué
produit par la république française
[Musique]